it's been Community noted the New York
Times as we covered yesterday changed
their headline on it three times uh you
made the point that they showed a a
picture under the headline on the front
page of the New York Times that was not
the hospital it hit a parking lot but I
want to show you because you're making
the point of how quickly the media just
takes hamas's word Hamas says something
and then the media the corporate press
just repeats it here's MSNBC reporting
what we now know to be a complete lie
but the Palestinian Health Ministry is
saying a hospital in Gaza City in the
northern end of Gaza has taken a direct
hit from an Israeli air strike they are
saying hundreds at minimum 300 people
have been killed in this strike now we
have not yet heard any comments about
this allegation from the Israeli
military but these images that are
coming out of Gaza City are absolutely
harrowing and how do we explain to
people that when they say the
Palestinian government or the
Palestinian Health Ministry they're
talking specifically about Hamas and as
you laid out they want as many dead
civilians or at least the idea of dead
civilians as possible I mean they're
Liars this is the part that's
astonishing you're literally taking the
word of the people who committed a
genocidal Massacre of Jews five minutes
ago and you're pretending that they tell
you the truth on these matters now we
know for a fact that Kamas lies about
this stuff on the routine they do it
routinely in 2014 the New York Times
admitted that Hamas their health
Ministry their so-called Health Ministry
lies routinely about casualty casualty
statistics The Washington Post reported
the same thing if you are a reporter in
the go strip you're only there because
Hamas is allowing you to be there what
that means that if you don't say what
Hamas wants you to say they will either
expel you or they will kill you everyone
knows this in the Gaza Strip and yet
they take at face value the the the the
proclamations of an actual honest to God
terror group and then when it turns out
that every element of the story is false
the it was a Palestinian Islamic Jihad
rocket it did not hit a hospital it hit
the parking lot next to the hospital
doing no actual structural damage to the
hospital itself when every single
element of the story turns out to be
false the media then say well you know
the story is now being contested it's
not being contested you guys blew it and
not only did you blow it you blew it for
a very particular reason which is you
were eager you were eager for a story of
an isra atrocity that you could use to
juxtapose with what happened on October
7th so you could go right back to your
moral equivalent nonsense thereby
exacerbating all conflict in the Middle
East and getting more Jews and Arabs
killed by the way because when conflict
Ares in the Middle East just Jews that
are getting killed Jews then have to go
in and kill the bad guys and that means
that a lot of innocent people are going
to
die